- What do you say?
I mean I try to educate my
children as much as I can
with the age appropriate
information obviously.
But you try, and it's
like some things are like,
God, I can't believe I have
to have this conversation
with my kid.
- Yeah, absolutely
- I can't imagine
you having to tell your boy, like hey,
this is how it is.
Like, that's not what you
want to tell your kid.
- Yeah, I tell my son all the time,
man, it's not a good conversation
but it has to be had.
I just always tell him, man,
police ever mess with you or whatever,
just do what they say.
You know, and that's it.
I mean you're right.
You have the right to say
and do whatever you want to,
but realistically we
want you to come home.
Just comply.
Do what you gotta do.
And come home.
Don't say nothing.
Say the least that you have to say.
And that's it.
And they might be doing wrong to him,
I still tell him just do what he has to do
or whatever in order to come home.
Because there's a lot of
heroes that aren't here.
You know.
And so, I mean, I want him to stand up
for how he feels or whatever,
but when he's by his self
at night, and there's
four police officers,
I need for you to come home.
And then you come get me,
and we go deal with it.
You know, and so I have to let him know
to just do what he gotta do
in order to get back to me basically.
- I'm sorry you even have
to have that conversation.
- Yeah, but it's like I
said, it's a conversation
that's been going on for all our lives.
My uncles, and my grandfather taught me
and I'm quite sure they
uncles and they grandfathers
taught them, so it's
just this mentality that
goes down and goes down or whatever.
But I tell you this much,
white people nice as hell lately boy, woo.
They been nice as hell.
I was at the grocery store
and I had 2 customer services.
(laughter)
I was like this is.
I was like this is all right.
Boy, I like this.